jaune au rouge violette ou bicolores un
véritable arc-en-ciel de tulipes avec
des formes différentes et des tiges plus
ou moins longue les visiteurs de la
cueillette ont le choix entre les 53 20
étaient proposés par la ferme de viltain
j'ai pris toutes sortes de variétés
différentes de tulipes il ya un grand
choix de couleurs et comme je suis une
habituée de la ferme de viltain je sais
que généralement les bulbes sont de
grande qualité donc les fleurs durent
longtemps bah les tulipes oui c'est vrai
je n'ai pas forcément pour ça mais là
cette saison et puis c'est sympa et puis
et puis ça va ça va égayer un peu notre
intérieur on sort de la morosité de
l'hiver les couleurs parce qu'ils ce
joli
valeur sur les tulipes blanches où les
reines de la nuit certaines se
démarquent par leur forme et leur nom la
variété perroquet qui une fleur avec
voyez un mouvement dans dans les pétales
et dentelées alors des tulipes ça se
conserve à peu près entre cinq et dix
jours en fonction de la température que
vous avez dans votre pièce ce qui est
peut être une bonne idée c'est le soir
de les remettre dans soit carrément
dehors ou dans une pièce plus fraîches
la cueillette des tulipes se poursuit
jusqu'à la fin du mois prochaine fleurs
à apparaître sur les parcelles de la
ferme de viltain les roses au mois de
mai et les lys en juin